[Music]
the impossible could not have happened
therefore the impossible must be
possible in spite of appearances
instinct is a marvelous thing
it can either be explained nor ignored
fear is incomplete knowledge
if you place your head in a lion's mouth
then you cannot complain one day if he
happens to bite it off
[Music]
an archaeologist is the best husband a
woman can have the older she gets the
more interested he is in her
time is the best killer
but surely for everything you love you
have to pay some price
the truth however ugly in itself is
always curious and beautiful to seekers
after it
[Music]
everything must be taken into account if
the fact will not fit the theory let the
theory go
the young people think the old people
are fools but the old people know the
young people are fools
words mademoiselle are only the outer
clothing of ideas
curious things habits people themselves
never knew they had them
[Music]
an appreciative listener is always
stimulating
i often wonder why the whole world is so
prone to generalize generalizations are
seldom if ever true and are usually
utterly inaccurate
a mother's love for her child is like
nothing else in the world it knows no
law no pity it dares all things and
crushes down remorselessly all that
stands in its path
it is a curious thought but it is only
when you see people looking ridiculous
that you realize just how much you love
them
[Music]
i don't think necessity is the mother of
invention invention arises directly from
idleness possibly also from laziness to
save oneself trouble
[Music]
you gave too much rain to your
imagination imagination is a good
servant and a bad master the simplest
explanation is always the most likely
good advice is always certain to be
ignored but that's no reason not to give
[Music]
very few of us are what we seem
[Music]
you